One of the things I'm most amazed by at the
moment is how the ideas and issues we're talking
about on The Rubin Report every week are relevant
not just in America, but resonate all over
the world.
The amount of email I'm getting from you across
the globe, whether it's from Sweden, Australia,
Brazil, Hungary, or even Japan is actually
staggering.
It really seems that there has been a re-awakening
as to what being a free human is all about.
You are in charge of your own life, and if
you start with this premise, you can accomplish
anything.
While the discourse on social media may seem
more toxic than ever, I see a growing, dynamic
group of people coming together through ideas
and conversation, regardless of where they
were born or the color of their skin.
My guest this week, Rajshee Agarwal, was born
in India to a traditional family, only to
move to America and now teaches about capitalism
at the University of Maryland, where she is
the Chair and Professor of Entreprenuership.
She believes capitalism provides maximum freedom
and happiness to all people, regardless of
race, religion or anything else.
An idea once sparked in her and now she is
helping further those ideas into the future.
That’s what freedom is all about.
If you want to join me in spreading these
ideas of freedom and individuality in person
I'll be joining Jordan Peterson on his 12
Rules for Life tour for as many events as
possible -- most of these dates are sold out
already, but some tickets are still available.
We kicked off the tour two weeks ago at the
Beacon Theater in New York City, where the
energy and enthusiasm in the room was off
the charts.
I'll be traveling with Jordan to the UK to
speak in London at the Apollo Hammersmith
Theater on May 13th, and then on May 14th,
I have the incredible honor of speaking at
the Oxford Union.
Hopefully I'll get to meet as many of you
as possible, and we can down a couple pints.
I'm also working on an Australian tour and
hope to have some more info on that for you
guys soon.
I've mentioned on the show lately the endless
hysteria of the Left and and the politically
correct craziness we're caught up in was eventually
gonna drag me back into stand up -- and this
finally came to fruition this past Sunday
at the Irvine Improv.
The show was billed as an evening of stand
up and sit down as I did about an hour of
stand up, and then Bob Saget joined me for
about 45 minutes of a sit down..
It was awesome seeing so many of you out there
and the show was a huge success.
The manager of the Improv told me it was the
first sold out standing ovation she's seen
at the club in 18 years.
Travel dates for upcoming stand up gigs will
be announced soon, come join me for two drinks
and plenty of laughs.
And finally, after years in the making, we
taped our interview with Dr. Thomas Sowell
yesterday on location at Stanford University
in San Francisco.
We flew our whole team up there and rented
a studio to make it happen.
It was truly a career highlight, and I can’t
wait to share our sit down with you next week.
Big thanks to our Patreon supporters who make
huge interviews like this possible.
So, all these announcements aside, whether
you're in the US, India, Oxford, San Francisco
or anywhere else, we're all in this fight
together.
Keep fighting for what you believe in and
I'll do the same...